yeah I know welcome to this video which
is a new rapid game on HS oh yes let's
do something entirely different it just
felt like it play color okay goes Knight
f3 so the two knights variation no he
takes it yeah taking at ninety five is a
funny side line maybe that's the white
idea you know place this one hmm okay so
this is essentially an exchange
variation with an early night to f3 you
don't see this all that often
one reason is probably that Bishop g4 is
a move that is on the agenda however I'm
not entirely certain okay he played it
completely differently about c4 was what
I wanted to same yeah this looks a
little bit strange to me honest put the
knight on c3 voluntarily that's normally
not where you wanted c3 is considered to
be the right way to set us out okay um
Age 3 yeah it seems like he wants to
prevent Bishop c4 that I understand but
so let's say I still can't develop this
how and he just wants a trade
well I can try to meet them Bishop g6
was an option but I don't think there
was a particular point in that maybe 94
actually was a woman no okay but this is
fine and I'm happy with this position
that looks like they reversed consulate
structure where the night is on c3 this
is not the end of the world of course
why can for example play 90 to 93
no need to spend much time on those
moves here and so I'm playing on the
queenside
that question is how exactly you can
play with before on put a knight on to
see four heads also an option okay I
start with this that's useful in many
cases but primarily it wants to go b5 so
let's go b5 I pull an IED in damage from
Bosnia okay and 95 now on something
something like this looks okay
sometimes an idea for white in such a
structure is the King side attack like
95 rookie 3 g3 these kind of maneuvers
[Music]
[Music]
it takes a bit of time there are
certainly a couple of options out also
well I wasn't sure and I was thinking
9023 let's I'm not sure that this really
helps all that much okay so if I take
and maybe pawn takes rook c8 was my
original intention I'm just to be
forcibly telling I don't think it's all
that dangerous
yeah let's see what he does this is a
more flexible move taking he might take
with the pawn and get the d4 square for
light that done wasn't sure about if I
want to allow it
my wife is why choice him look 81
million just centralizing sometimes you
can play the group the one that if I
play this night a 5c4 stuff just play
Bishop c1 back and defend Queen side
with the bishop
yeah we'll do a couple of things for
that move it still kind of not clear to
me what I want to do against it
I mean before should be ok but so ok
this this was definitely an option so I
wonder about 94 in such in this position
centralizing yeah I like this move 96 to
c4 becomes an idea end instead of
preempts 93 recharging which I will just
take general black is not so much
against training some pieces in this
position okay so here
we can now trade quite a bit I'm
wondering about something which sounds
maybe completely wrong
can i click on d4 here 9420 for Bishop
c5 that could work
I could actually work 94 first of all
declining it's not so easy and 94
pancakes looks good for me if it takes
with the Queen Bishop c5 the ship c5 the
queen is attacked there is no real great
counter check now Luke takes the fourth
risky but okay let's see the Queen has
to move and then well I cannot take on
f2 well I have I can take with the night
for form some nylons good yeah kind of
as amazing as this would this could work
but to believe it out of the blue I
don't see a move that's fascinating when
I get I get really good material
compensation there and and I think it's
a good position okay so here we go
[Music]
I was thinking of this motif earlier
here because like any like f3 I could
have taken sometimes because of that
Bishop c5 pin this is why the move
probably occurred to me in the first
place but even sure how I take on f2 I
mean the funny thing is if you imagine
three takes you should see five Queen
back to D 3 Rd one night f2 tempo on the
Queen and I have a big discovered check
coming so this is the only move that
makes any sense let's play it and now I
have a big discovered check coming and
let's say Queen D one night here that of
to Queen it died the Queen has to cover
the bishop so I say Queen f3 Knight
takes h3 King King edge 2 what I'm
getting at is that Queen h4 would be
made to just mate
huh there is no super clear way of doing
it I don't I don't know that necessarily
wins I mean I've got I got three pawns
and it looks pretty good but is it
winning I can also take on f2 with Czech
and just take the rook rather than I
have some points yeah well this is a
different story if I take on f2 now the
Queen okay can go to f3 as well okay
also can take here
hmm so night if two isn't all that clear
that's kind of amazing 9s too
you
or do I have other discolored check that
I'm currently not quite understand I
don't understand
we don't see it right f2 Queen H Queen
f3 Knight h3
don't don't quite maybe if I take F 4 at
the end and this is interesting if I
take m 4 at the end Queen takes Bishop
d6 intending f6 and I have fun
I have rook c4 in the mix oh I don't
know
it looks fascinating okay I can also
check if - of course just just like this
and it doesn't really doesn't really
look good so let's do this Queen f3
Knight h3 King h2 who I was thinking
take b56
I've got three pods anyway and I've got
some ideas there f6 look-see four weeks
see - maybe there no let it just
blunders the house here to go to f3
ah well here now that's a double check
can he cannot play there should be three
I just win every win the house now
and Queen f3 I think they won so I think
it was good for me as well but of course
not as good as this
[Music]
Queen age for mates is the threats of
Queen G for is the only move the ni g6
problem or Queen to f6 also it also
looks very strong threatening Queen h6
yeah that's a strong move on the wiki
Mavis started the Harley again oh my god
it really sounds sometimes like it
somebody get detonated something in the
neighborhood know which is the start of
that damn shopper
and the funny thing is that he would
just like take this chopper to drive
around the block and then return like
two minutes later it's it's completely
bonkers okay anyway um yeah Queen h6 is
the thing
9h five prints what I expect
then I'll take and probably be 56 woven
imp like a three paws up as well so you
don't need something completely to be
the maid or something
CIT resigned so let's have a look down
at the analysis yeah I think the the
opening phase but all that interesting a
93 is a little bit a little bit uncommon
in such a situation because you usually
want the policy three to make a good
loop on chain but okay it's not like why
this was here so this looks normal it
should be five years it's a bit more
with more fighting but I'm curious about
them set up here so a 65 so it's
normal-looking 95 accommodate yeah here
if for was a look that I was thinking
about that before looks good yeah there
is nothing special there I can check on
ID FOIA
white can take here when c2 is old
saying so I'm surprised at the end it
gives me an advantage a little bit but I
mean I'm a mom I'm okay here but I
wouldn't really thought I'm better
okay so Knight e4 yeah 93 years of
surprising blonde iron Knight takes d4
early works okay so the engine worked
out that in fact Knight takes e4 stood
as a playable position but Queenie for
CAD losses would see em so Knight takes
and now Knight C - okay yeah I was
actually intending just to to think
about that and then see two wings that
isn't all that clear bond now I don't
have a good square for the Queen and
always in those 96 discoveries okay the
engine and so pointed out this move not
something that would have occurred to me
naturally then ship here still not clear
so this is enough this is an option but
it's also not clear so the 93 isn't a
blunder I mean you shouldn't probably
allow this strike but it's not winning
Knight takes e4 is okay and but this
just seems to this seems to lose he went
back to d3 and Queen f3 are considered
to be the only move which is true so
then I am so I was right and this this
this this and now Bishop d6 was what I
was intending to play yeah with f6 and
rook see for being threats and it wins
yeah okay so I did this played this
correctly I mean it's not a big risk
anyway if you are somewhat unsure about
such a line I mean I've got three pawns
anyway and
the wide position is not very well
coordinated it cannot it cannot be bad
for like just a question how good is it
and in fact it turns out to be
completely winning which I wasn't sure
about during the during the analysis
during my calculation is the right word
yeah Queen e2 makes it of course of
Elysium here Queen f6 is the easiest the
easiest one threatening this will
becoming made and no moves really no
moves really okay hope you enjoyed the
video thanks for watching